all right man you ready to uh ready to
go I'm ready to go let's do it die man
so Zach it's uh it's a delight it's a
pleasure to finally have you in the
studio I've been looking forward to this
for a very long time ever since you blew
my mind
yeah conscious capitalism conference we
had a couple amazing conversations and I
was like dude I gotta you gotta like lay
down some truths if you come by the
studio so here we are thank you thank
you for making the time excited to be
here I appreciate the advice yeah I'm
trying to think like well first of all
also thank you
Julie has a migraine she's flat on her
back and so before we even started the
podcast for you guys listening out there
Zak put her through like an unbelievable
treatment and I appreciate that thanks
huh was beautiful she's amazing human
being yeah she's cool and she's you know
she's been doing everything in her power
to try to figure out like how to get on
top of these migraines and she's made a
lot of progress but every once in a
while like they just they just you know
they just rock her world and she's down
for the count for like two or maybe even
three days
I'm sure the timings not a mistake that
I was there when I showed up here
because I think a lot of times when we
find ourselves in those intractable
patterns one of the things I've seen as
a physician now for the last 17 years is
that we can never heal ourselves no
matter how much we know no matter how
much we research we can't heal ourselves
were called into community through our
ailments and so then her migraine may be
calling her in to mark meeting with more
people more than more research for
herself I think that that's a very
astute observation but also balancing
that against the fact that on a certain
level part of your message part of my
message is that we are we do have more
power than we allow ourselves to believe
when it comes to healing ourselves so
much so and and I think you know the
only thing that that civilization has to
fear right now is that power because
we've literally built an entire economy
of not just the United States but the
entire Western civilization on health
care and that's been a hidden reality
for a long time
but for thousands of years the real
control of populations has been around
their food and we find ourself in that
same you know if not amped up version
now that we have seven billion souls on
the planet that becomes very very big
business when you start to be able to
control food and we see that the
ultimate political control is around the
food chain and whether it delivers
health or not yeah absolutely and I feel
like you're somebody who's you know
having this conversation as the the hub
of this wheel upon which there are many
spokes that that you speak to that you
have some level of expertise on whether
it's you know Monsanto and glyphosate
and GMOs the the the microbiome you know
gut permeability inflammation autism
like all of these you know big pharma
big chemical and the interplay of all of
these and they seem like they're
disparate subjects and issues but the
more I learn about you and how you speak
about all of this clearly all of these
things are they're just part of this
very intricate web where they're all
interdependent upon each other and
contributing in in their own various
ways that's exactly and it's I've
basically found myself in a massively
reductionist state of my understanding
of the world around us when I hadn't
really spent you know 20 years of my
life studying medicine which was the
opposite where every year and minute you
study in that environment they try to
convince you it's more more complicated
that there's a thousand different
diseases that there's ten thousand
different drugs to treat those diseases
than but in reality what started to
deconstruct that world was the
realization that the cancer I was
studying under the microscope when I was
devising chemotherapy happened to be
really the exact same process as an
ulcer in the ankle of a diabetic patient
again sound totally disparate but the
end totally reductionist view point is
it's only one thing which is chronic
inflammation right so there was this
quest this idea of like getting to the
bottom of like what is it that's causing
disease in general and understanding
that you know the whole kind of
foundation of you know how you learn
medicine and practice medicine is
premised on the disease model of
understand
how diseases function as opposed to
studying and understanding how to
promote health and the mechanisms that
are behind health yeah and it's
interesting that even in the public and
in the in the medical world we've come
to almost embrace that in our lexicon
and that we say when it's this is
chronic disease management that's
exactly what Western medicine is is it's
trying to manage a disease rather than
induce health and the big tip-off to me
in this process you know Here I am in
the lab is developing chemotherapy and
so buried down the rabbit hole of the
pharmaceutical model but there was a big
tip-off starting to happen in the late
1990s and early 2000s that we were
seeing diseases in what seemed like
completely different organ systems in
the population go epidemic I
simultaneously examples of this was
certainly autism that you mentioned
earlier we had one in five thousand
children with autism in 1975 today we
have just three weeks ago released the
most recent data one in 36 children with
an autism spectrum disorder and the big
argument for a long time was well maybe
were just diagnosing and recognizing
autism better which is kind of laughable
if you've ever sat with an autistic
child here's a five-year-old who can't
speak can't make eye contact hits his
head on the wall for a few hours a day
to try to console his terror we didn't
miss that in 1975 you know this is not a
diagnostic dilemma but then to further
emphasize that the fastest acceleration
in that growth pattern of this epidemic
has happened between 2012 and today
where we're seeing a doubling time every
two to three years in that autism rate
that the current rate will see one in
three children with autism in 2035
that's insane and and similarly I mean
this is across the board as well right
you look at cancer it's one out of every
two people will be diagnosed with some
form of cancer before they die I'm not
even counting skin cancer that's like
solid team were in bone marrow cancers
at 50% now and then in 1996 we saw this
sudden rise and in the Alzheimers
dementia in women interestingly the
Alzheimer's rates has not changed in
males since that time but at the same
time 1996 we see this uptick and
consistent linear growth parallel to
that Alzheimers tract and women with
parkinson's and males and so we have you
know species
gender specific organ specific diseases
in the brain and peripheral cancers all
of which took off at the same time in
the mid-1990s autoimmune disease
unbelievable epidemic starting in the
late 1990s and so this was like the
cracks that were starting to form in my
worldview that maybe there weren't a
thousand different diseases because they
all started going epidemic at once which
really begged the question is there a
root cause if the root cause the root
cause of all disease and that's where we
found ourselves back into the food chain
mm-hmm and so you come to this
conclusion that inflammation not acute
inflammation chronic inflammation is
that the root cause or the sort of
common denominator consistent across the
board when you kind of canvass all of
these maladies so what does that mean
what are the implications of that what
are the causes of that and like where do
we go from here yeah so the first step
is to kind of consider what is
inflammation inflammation is actually a
normal biological response to an injury
the immune system lies throughout your
body in different shapes and forms but
some 60% of the volume of the immune
system and some 80 percent of the work
done by the immune system is done in
your gut lining and we the concept of
the gut is poorly defined and poorly
understood by the consumer as well as
doctors but it really starts in your
sinuses it is your barrier system
between the outside world and what you
breathe the outside world and what you
drink
eat etc this membrane is extremely
interesting to look at it in its
engineering I have an engineering
background my son's an engineer just it
seems obvious that if I was going to
engineer and a human being I would have
designed it differently right which
means I probably would have screwed it
up completely but it's such an
interesting under engineering event this
got membrane it it is the largest
surface area we have exposure to the
outside world it's two tennis courts and
surface area versus only the 1.8 meters
or so of your skin surface area so if
you have this massive surface area and
the only covering of that surface is a
cellophane like layer of and epithelial
cells of the gut and sinuses and the
rest that is about 50 microns in
diameter when I strike one cell thick
right one cell thick which is if you
pluck a human here and cut the
in half that's the that's the thickness
of your gut membrane so you have this
half a human hair cellophane layer that
protects you from every bite of food you
eat every chemical that comes into your
food chain etc so it seems like horrible
engineering but on the flip side it
tells us something about what we're
engineered for we need to be inherently
in contact with the ecosystem in nature
around us and if we start to tinker and
screw with that nature that membranes
going to become very vulnerable and
start to leak and our immune system sits
right behind that and so with 70% of
your immune system volume if we have a
chronic inflammatory epidemic in the in
the world which is a better definition
than lots of diseases then we must be
overwhelming the immune system of all of
the public for some reason at the same
time sometime between 1982 and 2000 we
had a did something to the environment
totally decimate the protection system
of our immunes immune systems you almost
have to be a historian a sociologist and
an anthropologist to really properly
contextualize all of this and understand
everything that that has come into play
to deliver us to this point and you know
I watched the what was it called GMOs
revealed yes series that you don't watch
the whole thing but I watched your
segments on it and you delivered this
amazing dissertation on on the history
of how we kind of arrived to this point
in in the context of you know glyphosate
and GMOs and monoculture you know dating
back to the 1920s in the Dust Bowl
through World War two and kind of all of
these geopolitical and economic events
that contributed to the current state
that we're in with respect to how we
feed the planet yeah so I think it's it
would be good to kind of canvass that a
little bit because I think it will it
will help and I've really contextualized
how we dig into the next section which
is talking about the microbiome and
these diseases how how they've come to
be and and what we can do to kind of
avoid them or reverse them perfect in
the same way that we've misunderstood
the gut and what got health means we
misunderstood soil for the longest time
and in the 1919 hundreds really the late
1880s we started to change the way we
farmed simple things happen like we went
to steel grinding for wheat instead of
stone grinding it which meant we could
get more of the fiber out of which means
we created a higher gluten and higher
refined carbohydrate load in our flours
and in our wheat system and everything
else so that's one example of a shift
but the main thing that happened as we
started to disrespect the importance of
crop rotation and soil rest cover
cropping etc this led to a massive death
of the topsoil which led to the Dust
Bowl that ran through the 1920s and 30s
and it's fascinating that here we are
only 80 years out from this event where
our ancestors you know two generations
three generations and we're literally
starving to death we had soup lines that
went for days you know across the entire
Midwest and houses were literally being
buried in dust of dead soil that had
died were not connected to history and
yet it never talked about that I don't I
don't remember the last time that ever
came up in the context of politics or
food yeah it's and we certainly didn't
learn the lesson that that presented
which is like hey man like maybe you
know step outside your hubris a little
bit and let's look at how the
environment actually functions and serve
that rather than continue to try to find
these shortcuts or sidesteps around what
nature is trying to explain to us
exactly and so yeah my grandfather just
passed away at ninety and he told
amazing stories of his childhood where
his family had one hog that they could
butcher a year
and they lived on a little farm raised
their own chickens everything else and
that one hogs meat had to feed the whole
family for a year you know and yet we
see you know a total forgotten as to
that kind of connection to our food
changing yet that's just two generations
back and so there's a lot of emphasis
these days in the press and in the
common literature of like paleo diets
and all this stuff when we don't have to
go back to cavemen to find a healthy
diet we need to go back 80 years you
know it was that close to our history
that we were in touch with raising our
own food that's during the Dust Bowl we
actually for the first time started out
so
our food production because these people
lost their local gardens and farms so we
started to rely on importing food for
the first time and we started as
outsource that concept then World War
two hit and we did something interesting
which was started a huge marketing
campaign for gardens and they were
called the Victory Gardens and everybody
in not just in the US but in the whole
Alliance through Europe and everything
else were asked to plant gardens in
their backyard to help support the
troops with food and by the end of World
War two we were growing 45% of our
entire food source in our backyards so
these victories are things like I'd
never heard that either I had no idea
and in some ways it's interesting as I
started my nutrition clinic in 2010 not
knowing any of those and I decided to
start in the poorest communities in
Virginia and so I was in rural Virginia
total food desert most people ate the
majority of their food out of gas
stations because there's not even
grocery stores to fuel the community so
they're literally surviving off of
Twinkies and little Debbie's and then
the hot dogs that rotate on those little
rotisserie is in a gas station you
always walk in like who eats those I
mean people are living on that is their
only staple so I went into this
community thinking this is gonna be the
hardest uphill battle ever to get these
people into a plant-based diet and it
turned out to be exactly the right place
to start the revolution because these
people were only one generation
disconnected from that because they were
fifth generation poverty they were
subsistence living to this day and when
I said you need to grow our parents were
farming probably exactly and so you say
you need to start a garden they're like
well grandma's garden is still out back
like it wasn't even a challenge for
their mind it's like oh yeah we just
need to replant the garden and I watched
families there was a great Baptist
minister down there yes african-american
Southern Baptist minister got this
message he'd had a couple heart attacks
diabetes etc : plant-based food was
gonna be his cure he said oh my gosh my
grandma had the biggest garden by the
time I left Scottsville this tiny little
community some five years later he was
feeding 40 families out of his own
garden
and so it's just you know we're right
there
now you contrast that with wealth and it
becomes challenging those CEOs fly into
my clinic from all over the place
thinking you know because they just had
a heart attack they hear about nutrition
clinic they come you say you need to
grow guard and they look at you like
you've grown another head like yeah it's
not even part of my reality you know so
it's interesting how wealth has really
been earned and recognized or won
through a march away from connection to
nature in a march towards convenience
living and so from our social structure
and our building of wealth around it
we've divorced ourselves from the
ability to be responsible and have an
opportunity engage with our own food
mm-hmm and and this weird inverse
relationship between obesity and
actually being nourished right so we
have these deserts and these people are
all completely you know completely
overweight morbidly obese but
tremendously undernourished tremendously
calorically replete and nutritionally
deficit total desert and so how does
that happen and it's interesting because
it comes down to kind of what started to
happen after World War two which is we
we had this huge petroleum industry that
was revved up bigger than it had ever
been in the history because we had all
tanks jeeps mechanized warfare for the
first time in human history on this
scale we had planes for the first time I
mean this was like full-out totally
different thing that had ever happened
in history and it was a world war much
different than World War one in its
scope and so we see this huge petroleum
industry that suddenly grinds to a halt
because the war is over so we have this
glut of petroleum when we suddenly
realized we can extract nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium out of that
coltan that oil and we started making a
chemical based fertilizers for the first
time right on a chemistry level they're
not that distinct correct like the
operative ingredients are essentially
the same with a little engineering you
can take this glut of petroleum and
repurpose it for a new commercial
enterprise yeah so they found a new
marketplace for this oil and it was a
great message to the farmers who were
still suffering with bad dirt in the
Midwest is like you don't need to deep
crop rotation you don't need a compost
you know don't need to go
back to thousands of years of farming
tradition just spray this chemical on
there yeah forget about whatever you
might have learned to read the Dust Bowl
yeah that was that was 40 years ago
that's ancient times we're modern now
yeah
and so these farmers started using it
and it became a revolution for them and
it was actually called the green
revolution of the 1960s and so the green
revolution was actually use of nitrogen
phosphorus potassium or NPK fertilizers
and the NPK fertilizer did turn plants
green because nitrogen and phosphorus do
that but what was lacking in those
plants for the first time in human
history was the nutrients and the
medicine that should always have been in
that food and so the plants became weak
just like a human being who lacks
nutrients their immune system goes down
and when a plant's immune system goes
down becomes prone to viruses pests and
it can't excrete the stuff from the root
system that would keep weeds at bay and
so now the plants are getting you know
attacked from the outside if you will
and the chemical farmer and chemicals
University says no problem here's a new
chemical weed killer here's a pesticide
and so the farmers got themselves locked
into this codependent relationship with
chemical fertilizers than chemical drugs
for the plants to keep them alive
despite a failing biology underneath the
surface they're right akin to taking a
drug to deal with the symptoms of some
ailments that you have that creates a
whole battery of side effects that then
require you to take another drug to deal
with those it's just a an environmental
version of that it's exactly the same
thing in fact the drugs have been the
same in a lot of ways the main drug is
antibiotics
Western medicine really got its first
foothold with penicillin our first
antibiotic and that happened to be in
the 1940s with world war ii you and so
we developed in the same decade the
antibiotics that would kill the bacteria
in our body with the antibiotics that
would kill the soil and I say antibiotic
because these chemicals that we were
using as Presta size are largely an
antibiotic rather than you know what you
would think of maybe a weed killer or
something and the most famous of these
of course has become roundup the most
single successful chem
warfare that's ever been sold on the
planet we currently sell and used four
and a half billion pounds of Khalifa say
which is the active ingredient in the
chemical to treat the soils of the earth
four and a half billion pounds of single
chemical annually that chemical was
never patented as a weed killer
it's only been patent as an antibiotic
and that was reap added as an
antiparasite it was yeah that was the
original purpose of it correct well it's
the mechanism it's the mechanism they
recognized and so the mechanism of
glyphosate is to go in and block enzymes
in the soil bacteria fungi in plants and
that enzyme pathway is called the
shikimate pathway and and it's important
because it makes a number of the
essential amino acids our bodies are
composed of over 200,000 proteins but we
only have 20,000 genes we have this
pathetically dumb genome in the sense
that flea has 30,000 genes so you're 2/3
as complicated as a flea at the gene
level which I find reassuring if I can't
find my keys or I'm having a bad day I'm
like am 2/3 and health care is a flea
what can i what are my real expectations
here but the reality is we very simple
at the genetic level and yet we make
over 200,000 proteins from a bunch of
amino acids there's 26 amino acids that
will build those 200,000 proteins those
26 amino acids are just like the 26
letters of the English alphabet in the
sense that the vast majority those are
useful but not critical but the vowels
these 8000 aren't language if you
subtract one of those vowels you can
affect hundreds of thousands of words
the vowels and the amino acid vocabulary
here is are the essential amino acids
which if you start to tweak any of those
9 you're going to start to lose tens of
thousands of protein structures in their
functionality and in their their unique
form and so there's essential amino
acids not only are they important like
the vowels they also can't be made by
the human body
so those 9 have to come from your food
chain somewhere and it turns out that
they are only made by the bacteria the
fungi and the plants you don't have a
Shikha mate pathway in your human cells
and so these essential amino acids are
blocked through this you can make a
pathway by roundup and so imagine
treating
a food chain with a chemical that blocks
the ability of these plants to make the
building blocks for a healthy human body
forget about a human its dog a cat any
mammal any complex multicellular biology
is going to depend on these essential
amino acids and we literally in the last
15 years subtracted out the ability to
build the body because we changed the
the 26 letters yeah there's so much to
talk about just in that alone I mean the
fact that I mean from my understanding
glyphosate was able to kind of pass
muster with the EPA and and you know
avoid sort of being out regulated by
virtue of the fact that this shicken may
pathway was a plant process not a human
process well it doesn't matter this is
the plant thing and again the hubris and
the kind of like lack of understanding
on behalf of human beings to appreciate
just how crucial this ChiCom a pathway
is and was at the time and will always
be - making the nutrients of these
plants bioavailable to us so that we can
use them and I think on a grander scale
it speaks to not only you know the
pitfalls of our reductionist approach to
science in general but also like us as
human beings always wanting to look for
that one solution that's going to solve
our problem like I'll just eat spinach
or kale and you'll be fine well that's
fine if the soil is the way that we you
know the way that it should should be
and these plants are grown the way that
nature intended them to be but you know
we're in a condition and a state right
now where glyphosate the use of
glyphosate is so profuse that it's
almost impossible to avoid this
situation altogether unfortunately
you're right you know and and you know
to go into that just briefly one of the
reasons I think that glyphosate was not
put on the market in 1958 when it was
discovered is because the Japanese
inventor of that chemical recognized
that that was a water-soluble type toxin
you do not want to introduce a
water-soluble toxin into the environment
because you can never get it back
right in that where if you have a
fat-soluble stalks and it'll actually be
sequestered by mycelium in the soil if
gets into a human or another Manimal
it'll be sequestered by fat cells so it
never hits the brain
it'll be protective a water-soluble
toxin on the other hand can't be
subtracted out of the ecosystem because
everything on planet Earth including
your human body is water and so that
means that sorry to interrupt but that
means that this chemical can pass
through that one cell you know that one
cell of the the gut lining and the the
brain blood barrier as well right
it's going everywhere and it's also
before you even gets the human body
going everywhere and so the current
statistics is that less than 1/10 of 1%
of the roundup used on the planet
actually hits a weed the other 99.99%
gets into the soil and in the water
system and washes off and so we are now
seeing the runoff from these farms and
in the water table itself so we have
fossil aquifers in the United States
here that run from Canada all right all
the way down to historically Mexico that
is now dried up we've we've turned over
a thousand square miles of Texas into
desert over the last 20 years from
sucking water out of the ground that
fossil aquifer is now contaminated with
roundup that's filtered down into this
ancient freshwater source for us and
then in the same moment you've got the
Mississippi River which collects over
80% of all the roundup in the country
and then it's evaporating the whole time
so it's going into the air that you
breathe and then it goes into the clouds
and then it rains down on us recent
studies in the air and rainfall in the
southern United States is showing 75
percent of rain 75 percent of air
containment and it was roundup so before
you even take a bite of who's you're
being hit with an antibiotic when you
breathe you're getting hit with an
antibiotic when you when you experience
rainfall and so you may be growing
organic crops but they're getting rained
on and so we have now locked this
water-soluble toxin into our environment
fortunately you know to give you a
little bit of breather here from the bad
news is that there are bacteria and
fungi that can eventually digest the
glyphosate the downside is we need to
stop spraying it so they can return
we're decimating those very bacteria and
fungi by the presence of roundup to the
point where they're not digesting in
current estimates is if we stop spraying
roundup tomorrow it would take about 50
years before you go system saw a drop
and level around up below our toxic
levels and what what is the current you
know market cap isn't the right word but
like how Pro few like huh like it's
billions of dollars right is there is
there anybody outside of the organic
farming community that does not use
roundup or people that are even just
weeding their own gardens at home and
spraying their lawns actually we're
started so before we genetically
modified crops to be able to be sprayed
directly with roundup in 1996 that that
occurred but before that it was really
the homeowner that was contributing most
to our toxin load because in the 1980s
the EPA allowed Monsanto to go direct to
consumer with their advertising for this
chemical and so they created those Super
Bowl commercials of a guy walking out of
his suburban garage with a dramatic
soundtrack and he had to pistol grips on
his side and he came out and boldly
sprayed down the four dandelions that
were drunk in his driveway which
happened to be super food that kill
cancer but anyway he sprays these four
dandelion kills the two kills the only
medicine on his property and you know so
suddenly it was it was by far and away
the most effective direct consumer
advertising ever and ever because
suddenly males in the United States
realized it could be manly
to weed right they're like shooting guns
they're shooting guns they're it's easy
warfare you know whatever it is instead
of having to actually bend over and put
on a pair of gloves or whatever it is
and so we started broadcasting this
stuff across driveways sidewalks patios
into our own you know garden spaces and
everything else and now the difference
between a homeowner who's going to go
through a couple gallons and a farmer
who will go through tens of thousands
gallons the farmers super careful with
the usage because their margins are so
low the phone the homeowner doesn't care
so they're spraying it down and they
might use a quarter of a gallon of
glyphosate in an afternoon whereas the
whole farm might treat the entire
thousand acres with that same quarter
gallon so the the
the smaller the user in some ways the
more dumping of this chemical date they
were doing so by the 1980s we were
drinking roundup out of our municipal
water system getting into our water
system that's unbelievable well let's
take a moment and and and just kind of
you know canvass what the discussion is
around glyphosate because I think you
know it's worth mentioning that as soon
as you bring this up we start to venture
tiptoe into this world of like you know
crazy conspiracy theories and you must
be you know some some you know insane
hippie person to be bringing this up and
you know don't don't mind him like he's
just a wacko
he's a whack job as a marginal character
you know we know this stuff is safe it's
been around forever it's been vetted you
know the EPA they're on it they know
what's you know they know what's healthy
for us if it was dangerous they would
have outlawed it and this has been
around for a long time and there's no
indication that anybody is getting sick
from this so what are you talking about
yeah if the conspiracy theorist was
right then we'd see 1 & 2 people with
cancer we'd see 1 in 30 kids with autism
we'd see Parkinson's going crazy and
they're literally repeating back if if
if it was toxic we would see literally
what we're seeing you know and so the
reality is the public health statistics
have gotten so grim in the last eight
years that nobody can call this a
conspiracy theory anymore but it's
almost like yeah but that's where's the
direct where's the smoking gun smoke the
gun is what's been missing that's what
we found in 2012 so in 2012 we found it
backwards I don't think anybody's
actually smart enough with the human
gray matter that were given to actually
create a paradigm shift prospectively
hey so every great you know mind that we
look to in past Galileo or you know Ben
Franklin or anybody we said ho they
discovered something or you know Edison
these just came at moments when the
evidence got so overwhelming that it
would became obvious right and so in the
same way in 2012 the evidence was
getting so overwhelming that we were
onto something in the nutrition world
but we at the time I was still thinking
cancer a cancer therapy because my
background was in chemotherapy
development and so when I found these
molecules in soil that looked similar to
the chemotherapy I had been making
a lot of bells started ringing I'm like
what is that where'd it come from how is
there medicine in the dirt like what
where's that coming from
and within a few weeks of that discovery
of those molecules we found out that
bacteria and fungi were making these
specific shapes of these carbon
molecules and that really closed the
loop for me because there had been some
papers coming out in the mid-2000s in
the cancer world that we're starting to
say that the bacteria in your gut were
predicting which cancers you would get
if you're missing these bacteria you
would get prostate cancer if you have
these bacteria you would get breast
cancer that was so radically bizarre and
out there for our current model even to
this day as to how cancer worked but now
you fast forward eight ten years and now
there's tens of thousands of articles
that are showing that genomically the
bacterial genome is way more important
in determining cancer than the human
genome and and so this reality was
hitting in so in 2012 when we discovered
these chemicals that look a little like
chemotherapy that are made by bacteria
and fungi in the soil it suddenly closed
the loop of oh my gosh what if the
bacteria in our gut is doing the same
thing what if the bacteria and the fungi
are actually our best source of medicine
for everything and so that's the
direction we were going but as soon as
we put this into petri dishes with
cancer cells and beyond we suddenly
realized not another there's something
way deeper happening with these this
information stream coming out of
bacteria and fungi and it was my chief
science officer dr. john gill day is a
PhD in genetics and and cell biology and
he was the first to realize that we had
put our finger on the glyphosate
toxicity issue is that this
communication network from the bacteria
and fungi was actually supporting the
protein structure in our gut lining and
so it turns out that the gut is held
together these trillions of cells that
make up that cellophane layer by tight
junctions these are velcro like proteins
that hold one microscopic cell to the
next to create this coherent carpet of
two tennis courts and he had recognized
before this and a number of other labs
had started to publish that glyphosate
seemed to increase the permeability of
this membrane and nobody was really sure
why yet but we suddenly realized that if
this bacterial communication network was
in there we we couldn't injure the in
the membrane we it became bulletproof
to the glyphosate injury and so in that
journeying we start a really study
glyphosate in its relationship to the
human cells because like you said
Monsanto has been swearing up and down
that there is no harm to the human body
because the sugar may pathway I want
existed back here in fungi well that may
be true regarding that enzyme target but
the classic thing with any drug is it
always has off target effects all right
and so that's why drugs have side
effects is they don't actually go and do
exactly what your doctor says it's going
to go do it's gonna hit a bunch of the
receptors and do other things the side
effects of glyphosate that are outside
of this Shikha main pathway is direct
injury to the protein structure that
holds your gut lining together this
would be bad news if that was it but it
turns out that every macro membrane in
your body the blood vessels that that
fuel your entire body with oxygen
nutrients are held together with the
same tight junctions the blood-brain
barrier that protects your peripheral
nervous system in your brain same tight
junctions the kidney tubules that are
held together to detox your body same
tight junctions and so what's happened
as we've introduced a chemical that's
directly toxic to this this velcro-like
protein is we turn into leaky sibs on
the front-end gut leak and nasal sinus
leak and so every time we breathe every
time we eat we're starting to leak in
our immune system gets overwhelmed and
then the blood vessels that are supposed
to deliver either an immune response
from peripheral or get nutrients to some
distant space is also leaking and so
we're getting permeability of the blood
vessels then you get to the blood-brain
barrier this is supposed to be the Holy
of Holies a peripheral nerve or the
brain is supposed to be protected
against everything in your blood because
even glucose which is the main fuel for
your brain should not get into the brain
in an unregulated fashion it will damage
the nerves and so Holy of Holies of the
central and peripheral nervous system is
being destroyed and so if that's true if
glyphosate was really damaging that then
we should see a massive explosion in
neurologic injury to children and adults
starting in about 1996 and that's
exactly when we see this steep increase
happening in autism Alzheimer's
Parkinson's neurodegenerative conditions
like ms autoimmune diseases and all the
rest
that just blows my mind I mean it's
unbelievable essentially what you're
saying is this compound glyphosate
undermines the integrity of how your
body kind of holds itself together
essentially precise it's not only the
gut that starts leaking all these other
systems start to fail because they're
the permeability of those cell linings
is compromised correct and so correct
this creates an enhanced chronic
inflammatory response that is also
undermined because the delivery of that
response is compromised by the
permeability of the circulatory system
and the and the the the the gut the
ducts or whatever right that are all now
leaking as a result of this precisely
and there's something more amazing
happening even under that surface so the
tight junctions are like these spot
welds at the top of this cell membrane
it's hard to picture something that's
half the width of a human hair having a
top and a bottom but on our microscope
it actually looks quite large and at the
top of it you have the tight junctions
that are welding these cells together at
the at the midpoint of the cell you have
something called gap junctions these are
the most beautiful structures I've ever
seen under a microscope you can actually
Google this if you google electron
microscopy gap junctions blow your mind
here what it's showing you here is now
you're down to just a few microns in
diameter so you know 20 times thinner or
a hundred times thinner than a human
hair you have these clusters of fiber
optic cables that run from one cell to
the next
and there can be 10,000 of these fibers
in a single cluster that that is just
running in a very small space between
the cells and they are perfectly formed
tubes at this tiny microscopic level
that run from one cell cytoplasm to the
next and at the endpoints at under
higher magnification you can see that
they have a perfect camera lens aperture
the same shape and size that you expect
with a camera aperture with those
beautiful spiraling things that spiral
in and out to open and close and allow
light in or at the end of every one of
these fiber optic cables we we don't
realize it but we are
Light Beings we don't communicate
through hormones as our primary thing
our primary mechanism of communication
is through light energy and the
trafficking of electrons and light from
one cell to the next
the amazing thing that we've seen with
my cancer background and now looking
into this gap Junction phenomenon is
that when you start to break those cells
apart and you lose not just the tight
junctions that regulate the flow of
material but the gap junctions that
regulate the communication from one cell
to the next within 15 minutes under the
microscope we can see a normal small
intestine or colon cell start to take on
the morphologic features of cancer hmm
so it's the communication between the
cells that gets compromised because
these tubes are damaged yes imagine you
know a fiber optic system connecting
your office building somebody comes on
clips all your fiber optic cables you've
become now an isolated entity as a
company your company's gonna fail very
quickly you can't talk to your customers
you can't talk to your sales support you
start to fail that's exactly what's
happening to the complex company or
organization that a cell is as soon as
it gets lonely it can't receive
information can't figure out what it's
supposed to be doing today and it starts
to lose self identity which is exactly
what a cancer cell is a cancer cell is
simply the most damaged cell in your
body because it's not been able to met
mobilize repair processes and it's
gotten so isolated that it forgot it's
part of you and it thinks it's the only
thing left alive and so it starts to
divide like crazy it's the only thing it
can survive as opposed to what is it
called apoptosis right which is the net
when everything is functioning properly
that would take over and it would it
would be kind of performing its own
suicide exactly and so apatow SACEUR
this other concept of a toff adji which
is this Auto fade your consumption of
damaged cells both of these phenomenon
happen when a highly damaged cell is
still in communication with its
neighbors it says oh my gosh I just had
major genetic injury from over sunshine
or whatever the source or some chemical
in the food all I need to do is kill
myself and the stem cell will come and
replace me instantaneously that breaks
down when you get isolation loneliness
and you start to have one
opportunity to survive which is
proliferate and so these tumor cells are
by far and away the most damaged and
lonely and and really weakest cells in
the human body and yet we've built a
four hundred eighty billion dollar
chemotherapy industry to go try to kill
the most damaged weak vulnerable cells
in your body and it's a completely
backwards thing I get that and I get you
know the leaky gut and all the kind of
autoimmune disorders that would occur as
a result of the gut permeability being
compromised but how does this function
like what is the mechanism with respect
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's perfect so
there's it turns out that you know again
the humbling journey that I've been on
is to recognize as a doctor and perhaps
just as a human is we are barely human
when it comes down to the sheer number
of nonhuman cells we carry within us
that we are completely dependent on we
are just a fraction human to give you a
sense of the numbers we're somewhere
around fifty trillion human cells that
sounds like a massive number it's one of
the few numbers you hear that's larger
than our national debt it turns out that
we have somewhere on one-and-a-half
quadrillion bacteria and probably ten
times that in fungi and so we have 14
quadrillion mike microbiome
elements within our body and then we
have 14 quadrillion mitochondria that
live inside ourselves the mitochondria
look like bacteria but their DNA
actually looks like a virus it's a
little ringed DNA strand and that that
organism lives inside ourselves it's
about a hundred times smaller than a
bacterium and these guys are teeming in
our cells the average human cell when
we're born has 200 mitochondria per cell
and if you go look at any biology
textbook is going to show you two or
three mitochondria inside a cell not
right yeah that's what I always thought
I always thought there was just one or
two or more maybe usually just one one
right yeah
but I knew that you could influence that
like a lot of endurance training is
about increasing that mitochondrial
density yes I realized 200 200 per cell
and it gets crazy when you talk about
the brain that you just asked about a
neuron can have 2,000 mitochondria in
the axon Noor and then
body and so the brain is the most ATP
demanding organ we have when we're
asleep for example you think of the 70
trillion cells in our body that are
teeming way and working all the time 50%
of the calories burned at night are
entirely burned by the brain and so it's
this incredibly demanding energy energy
suck is the neural environment and so
that's gonna be the first therefore to
show damage to the mitochondria and the
a hallmark of Parkinson's and and all
the Alzheimer's conditions is that we
start to leaves mitochondrial shape and
form and therefore their productivity of
not just ATP which is the fuel we run on
but also the metabolites that are burned
through those mitochondria that are our
communication network that goes through
those fiber optic cables that we just
talked about and so in the course of a
neurodegenerative process we lose energy
and we lose the healing kind of
potential in the intracellular
environment because we're losing that
communication network and is that the
same mechanism at play with autism when
we're talking about this sort of gut
brain injury precisely precisely and
there's so there's threefold to the
autism thing and they can all map back
to exactly what we've talked about every
autistic child will have a very abnormal
microbiome they have horrible gut issues
typically like green stenchy stools a
lot of them diarrheal illnesses you know
a lot of irritable bowel bloating
constipation the whole pattern and then
they have leak and so they're highly
permeable across all their systems and
they cannot detox and so if you're
looking at the blood and the hair
analysis and a bone marrow biopsy for
example of a child with autism versus a
non affected sibling in their home that
kid is gonna be loaded with mercury and
other toxins from the environment that
their siblings and family that are
eating the same food same environment
aren't experiencing so that an autism
child is the ultimate leaky sieve and so
everything in their environment starts
to do it and one of the troubles of
chronic inflammation is once it occurs
it actually accelerates this sponge-like
effect for other toxins to follow and so
our children are turning into these
sponges for
and that autism thing expressing itself
after that leak happens the mitochondria
of course are being damaged at a very
high rate because they are the front
line of all these toxins coming through
the food chain and they're super
sensitive to and so they start to lose
mitochondrial capacity we do a study in
our lat in our clinic that's called a
phase angle that measures the the
electrical potential across a single
cell and that study shows us that an
optimal health we can run around a level
of 10 we die around a level of a 3.5 if
our electrical charge drops down to 3.5
we lose the ability traffic water and
other nutrients across cell membranes we
die quickly and so between 10 and 3.5 is
kind of where life can happen as we age
that number tends to drop so we can get
a kind of biologic snapshot of a child
coming into the clinic based on its
phase of phasing or an adult for that
matter but it's startling to find that
we can find four year old five year old
children with autism that have a phase
angle equal to an 85 year old person and
so we're what we're seeing with autism
is an acceleration of the aging process
at the neural environment that is is
akin to elderly dementia but at age two
no precipitated by this chronic
inflammation precipitated by first the
vulnerabilities than the leak then the
chronic inflammation then the drop in
mitochondrial potential then the
inability to hydrate the inside of the
cell and what kind of studies and
research have you done on us I assume
you've published on these issues it's
been really interesting to watch and
watch that so we've put a ton of science
out in the form of white papers and then
we got a couple of peer-reviewed journal
articles published in the last two years
we have clinical trials that are ongoing
that'll be published in this next year
and so it's been a really fun journey to
watch this happen but in the same time
we've seen massive
results at the individual level and so
we now have over a hundred thousand
users of the product consistently for
the last five years and we've seen just
you know miracles after miracles that
that only take one person to show right
you don't need a large clinical trial
hundred thousand people to show
something dramatic and so in this
journey we
our patients have really taught us more
than than our science lab because you
can tell so much by the complexity of
human a say our byes our ultimate
biology kit and it's telling us exactly
what's happening at a thousand different
levels simultaneously
and so when you see people who have had
chronic inflammatory conditions for our
you know decades suddenly reverse that a
you know it's not a product that did
that the only thing that can reverse the
you know disorder of that kind of
long-standing state is the human body
itself
you're regaining your own innate
capacity to heal which every cell has
the capacity to do that we already
mentioned apatow SACEUR program social
suicide but long before you get to the
suicide stay to the cell you've got tens
of thousands of machinery running all
the time in the form of enzymes that are
correcting DNA damage doing protein
analysis and breaking out damaged
proteins recycling those kicking this
whole thing in and so what we have seen
with this communication network from
bacteria and fungi is its orchestrating
the extracellular matrix environment
which is the first time we've ever had a
supplement take care of this environment
of the tight junctions the gap junctions
and beyond and so as it makes so much
sense in the end when you think about
where two bacteria and fungi live in the
human body well they live outside of
ourselves right outside of ourselves is
a very unprotected space much like the
soil in your garden inside your cells
were taken care of by our mitochondria
and they make oxygen based redox
molecules that are that communication
electrical energy that goes to the fiber
out change channels oxygen redox
molecules can't survive outside the
protected environment on the inside of
the cell and so it makes sense that the
bacteria and fungi that first developed
in the soil perhaps became adept at
communicating across long distances in
uncontrolled environments and the way in
which they did that is this family
molecules that we discovered in 2012 it
has a huge carbon backbone that makes it
stable in any sort of pH osmolality etc
and that stability allows one bacteria
to talk to another bacteria at a
distance I or one fungi to pass
information on to another or in this
case when they touch the human cell
surface the the microbiome is
communicating with the mitochondria so
we've showed direct communication
between a sterile product there's no
bacteria and fungi in the product
restore that product is
when it goes in we see the mitochondria
shipped within minutes of introduction
to something that's sitting on the cell
membrane produced by bacteria and fungi
and the mitochondria changed their
behavior they will tip a damaged cell
into Apatow SACEUR program cell suicide
in a few hours they will reduce the
stress and a healthy cell so that
there's less reactive oxygen species and
a reduction in metabolic demand by a
healthy cell and this is the first time
we've ever seen any family of molecules
do the opposite thing in a damaged cell
population versus a healthy cell
population so in other words what it's
doing is it's it's tending to I'm trying
to break this down in the most
elementary way to kind of comprehend it
it's tending to certain physiological
processes that have to do with how the
the gut flora behave and interact with
each other as opposed to treating the
human cells and the byproduct of that
dance that interaction has a positive
impact on the human cells that allow
them to repair themselves and begin to
function the way that they're meant to
is that precisely right and so accurate
okay this is really what we call this as
a liquid circuit board you know and so
this is a liquid supplement that's
electrical exchange and has electrical
exchange property to it and so picture a
liquid circuit board or perhaps even
better picture a wireless network and so
we're talking about cell communication
in the human biology but now picture
your cell phone your cell phone has a
computer in there that can transmit and
receive information called a phone call
at any time and it never it's not broken
when you stop receiving cell signal
right but if you're more than seven
miles from the closest cell phone tower
it suddenly becomes worthless as a
communication device and in its
isolation it will start to fracture
right you so yet in fragmenting of the
programs on your phone you'll start to
degrade as cual you can't update your
email you're losing communication is
everything so though in that in that
case the wireless network is not from
the cell phone it's from these cell
phone towers that are outside of the
cell phone in producing this this
invisible electron potential or this
frequency resonance potential for the
phones to communicate by same thing
happening at our cell level your brain
needs to communicate with your liver
your live
needs to communicate elsewhere we've
always thought in my field of
endocrinology and metabolism that was
done by hormones when we now know it's
doing much more through these redox
signaling molecules with the electricity
or through the micro RNA from our genome
and all these other things that are
traveling through space and time in the
more atomic physics environment rather
than the biology and so we've got this
very interesting reality that we
function as wireless networks and the
reality is really getting interesting as
we studying the micro RNA and all these
communication things between species
that we're starting to realize that we
are controlled at the genetic level by
these subtle messages from other species
from currently as we sit here some 35 to
40 percent of the the on/off switch is
in the the micro RNA that will
manipulate the behavior of our genes to
make the body we have today are not from
you they are from the bacteria and fungi
around you it's the bacteria and fungi
are literally changing the body you
build the day the sheer numbers of
bodies you could build based on our
current understanding of the genome and
protein synthesis is that you have the
opportunity for million different bodies
today out of your stuck genome you
inherited genes from mom and dad and
that seems very static but because each
gene can make over 200 different
proteins you can build yourself four
million different biologies today that's
insane and you've done that in your life
didn't you I mean you took yourself from
you know kind of a desk job to one of
the most elite athletes on the planet
you did that by building a completely
different human body yeah I mean it's
sort of it explains but it also kind of
takes it takes you know takes the study
to a next level that adage of like well
every since seven years you're a
different person or every ten years or
whatever it is but take that down to
seven seconds just seven seconds yeah
like the yeah and the idea that you can
enhance that and control it and kind of
corral it depending upon what you eat
how you behave what you're inhaling all
of these things that are creating this
this insane insanely complex interplay
of all of these living entities inside
yourself
that contribute to health or disease and
what's beautiful about it like the the
the mechanism and the design is just so
baffling and beautiful because what's
true of the microcosm is true of the
macrocosm and you know to the extent
that you're speaking about what's going
on in our gut and the impact that has on
our health or whether we're going to be
afflicted by a certain disease is
equally true when we talk about the Dust
Bowl and how we're growing food and how
we're feeding the planet yeah yeah and
it is liberating I mean all of this has
sounded like a lot of bad news but
identifying a problem is so much of the
solution you know and so now that we
identify the problem look we've we've
put into our food chain a chemical that
deletes the ability to build a healthy
human body we've put into the food chain
a chemical that deletes the medicine out
of our food which we didn't have time to
talk about but that shame ChiCom a
pathway makes the alkaloids which are
the medicinal features of our food is
deleted by glyphosate so we we can build
a diseased body we build a food chain
that doesn't have the medicine in it and
then we take away the most vital thing
which is this microcosm macrocosm
phenomena you just talked about so far
I've been describing to you that we are
losing the identity between the outside
world in our immune system by the
breakdown of these membranes we get
leaked that's literally taking away self
identity from the immune system and so
we get autoimmune disease where we're
starting to react to our own body as if
it was foreign in the same way at the
macro level
I believe we're losing our self-identity
as human beings as we start to leak and
we start to become majorly depressed
panic disorder we start to get lost down
these rabbit holes of doubt insecurity
fear guilt we have spiritual crisis we
have relationship crisis that's on an
epidemic level equal to cancer and
beyond the ability to stay in human
relationship seems to be the most
complicated thing that we could possibly
endure right now it's because we are
literally losing self-identity at the
cell level because we are eating a
chemical that breaks or self-identity at
the cell level that's that is
fascinating but it's true when you look
at the depression statistics you look at
the mental health statistics you know
you look at the opiate Explo
like all of the indicia are there that
we are ailing you know emotionally and
spiritually and mentally as a society as
much as we are physically yeah I think
there's exceptions to that I think you
see this in the in the disease process
which isn't so interesting
a sickness happens and it results in an
immune reaction in the healing process I
think that's what's happening to our
society right now we have a sickness and
a disease on the planet of loss of
self-identity in human consciousness of
our purpose here only to trigger the
ultimate healing process which is to
realize that we're on one we are on one
mission to find truth in ourselves and
through one another and ultimately like
we started the conversation with about
your wife where we are calling in
community we are going to overcome the
isolation of our cellphone era we're
going to start to touch each other more
we're gonna hug each other more because
we have to and that's a beautiful
healing process that I already see afoot
in the world around me and I'm blessed
to be able to go and speak all over the
world right now and I'm blessed in that
journey to see humans changing their
macro consciousness as they change their
diet as they change their nutrition as
they get in touch with their food chain
as they put bacterial and fungal
communication networks back into their
body they come back 18 months later to
my clinic and they'll say doc I just
left my husband he's been abusing me for
35 years and I finally realized I don't
deserve that and I left and so the you
know a woman can in an instant suddenly
realize as her boundaries go up at the
gut and at the blood-brain barrier her
macro boundaries if that's not
spiritually and psychologically
appropriate I am me I am I am important
I am loved I don't need that kind of
abuse in my life in the same way I'll
have somebody can walk in and say doc I
just quit my job I just started my
company that I've been wanting start for
thirty years and wasn't confident enough
to start and I just realized I am ready
and I just did it and so I have this
goosebump experience over and over again
despite some of the you know tragedy
that's in the talks that I gave in the
science that I now know and
I'm constantly seeing this bubbling up
of human hope and human healing and
consciousness coming on and I take great
hope in that I take great excitement
that if a few of us can become conscious
and aware and awake right now it has a
ripple effect that is so quick and it
has to be quick because one thing we can
be certain with no matter what
background we come from scientifically
or politically we can agree that any
society faced with 1 in 3 children with
autism will collapse under a financial
blow that is in escapable and so we're
about 16 years away from shore complete
collapse of our financial status as a
country and yet we don't hear a single
politician talking about we don't
because why because the politicians are
not the solution you and I are the
solution as consumers and we are doing
it already
the organic food movement nobody
predicted Alec's successful is going to
be ten years ago it was less than 1% of
the food sold in the country and now
we're pushing it you know we're up to
maybe four or five percent in a lot of
communities if we can push that to 16
percent these are numbers that were
apparently leaked from Monsanto in their
marketing analysis if the American food
chain became 16 percent organic Monsanto
and chemical farming would lose its
financial stability and is that right
only 16 16 percent have some energy
clearing in the room it's already
cracked I took it off the table I think
is saying that the time-space continuum
is now over I know it's going well yeah
well you're shattering the shadow my
blood brain barrier or something
I appreciate the optimism you know I
think that that it is easy to get
pessimistic when you look at the
statistics and you mine into them and
and you know I'm glad to hear that that
you're living in the solution and it is
about consciousness and I think it's
very interesting and I think it's unique
to hear somebody like yourself who is
such a hardcore scientist with an
engineering background to talk about
consciousness and the war for our
attention and the imperative of raising
the bar when it comes to our
consciousness because that is what it's
all about and you know my own experience
has been one of continually attempting
to raise the bar on my own consciousness
and as I do that I become healthier and
my world and my community expands around
me and it can seem ephemeral and it
sounds you can start to sound like a
hippie when you talk about this kind of
thing but it's very real it's very true
in my own life and I've seen it at work
in so many other people that it's you
know as far as I'm concerned it's its
fact and this is the conversation that
we need to be having and I find great
comfort that somebody from the
scientific community is willing to
embrace and have a discourse on that
level and it's interesting I think if
you talk to any physician or or healer
that's been in the industry for you know
40 or 50 years they're all gonna reflect
on their career the same way they're
never going to tell you about the
science and never to tell you about the
drugs
they're going to tell you about a few of
the relationships they had with their
patients I think we don't even know it
as physicians but we are wired for this
too we're wired for human consciousness
and relationship and it's why we go into
the field and then we get that buried in
a bunch of science and drugs and fear
and insecurity that we've been given a
bad tool box to take care of people so
we are failing at our ability to help
sustain health and improve the quality
of health of our patients so we get
defensive and we get fearful but in
reality all of us no matter how
scientific or artistic if it's not
relationship it's not real yeah and
that's true for work it's true for play
it's true for for a relationship
obviously so I think that once we start
to use that as our filter for our
success in the day we'll have a much
different definition of success and
failure
what's interesting about your journey is
that it all kind of happened
organically as a result of you trying to
understand health as opposed to the
mechanisms of disease that you were
taught in medical school and I thought
it was fascinating how you speak about
and when you start treating these
patients with healthy food and and many
of them are growing their own food and
yet 40 percent of them or some some
significant fraction
them still weren't getting better right
which was kind of like a lightbulb
moment for you it's exactly right so we
start our nutrition center in 2010 and
I'm kind of a go big or go home kind of
personality and so when I went to start
juicing my patients we went out of
control we were like four pounds of
produce a day you know we were really
going aggressive and some 30% of those
patients like you were saying a
miraculous almost instantaneous reversal
of chronic disorders and disease in
contrast there was 30% that would kind
of smolder along maybe get a little bit
of better in this area or that and then
there was this you know third or 40%
that we're getting worse instantly on
health food you know we're feeling the
best food on the planet and yet they're
getting their inflammation markers are
going up rashes are getting worse their
arthritic joints are getting worse they
are sick and it took me a while
two years of that to start to believe
that the patients were doing what I
asked each eating they must be cheese
must be drinking soda on the side and in
what always solves that misperception or
judgment or denial is relationship and
so I finally got into relationship with
these patients long enough or they were
like kin to me you know and I started to
realize oh my gosh they're trying so
hard and they're doing exactly what I'm
asking them to do and they're getting
worse and so then we started asking
wonder if there's somebody intrinsic
lady happening in the food because at
this point I didn't know anything about
Roundup I didn't know anything about
chemical farming I was just doctor
trying to lead in nutrition and so I was
thinking macronutrients and
carbohydrates and fat I was not thinking
about chemical industry at all and so as
we started to ask questions about the
food we started to realize there's good
studies right now how it's showing that
a tomato has almost no lycopene left in
it compared to the tomato the 1950s like
looks super red and it looks better than
the tomato and I just made a couple
spots on it and maybe a yellow spot it
wasn't this red orb with no flaw on it
because it's grown in a hydroponic
garden that hazard never touches the
soil and so they look great but there's
good science now showing that our food
has literally been deleted of the
nutrients and not just the fuel but the
actual medicines within it and so in
that journey then we started asking what
the heck happened
the tomato that had lost all of its
nutrients and then obviously the next
question was where's what must get that
from the soil and it was in a 90 page
you know white paper and soil sciences
that I found that molecule that would
shift my whole universe in 2012 yeah
it's crazy
and it really speaks to this the
importance of really considering the
macro when it comes to nutrition like
it's one thing to say like Oh eat a
plant-based diet get your greens or
whatever or or you know make sure you're
getting a lot of fruit and vegetables
but if you don't have an appreciation
for how when and where those foods were
grown and everything that goes into that
then as well intentioned as you may be
you very well may be missing the mark
exactly and I would actually I think we
can circle this right back to this
concept of relationship and
consciousness what's the difference
between a tomato that's grown by your
child in the backyard and you guys go
out there and attended every day evening
and that kid grows up for a summer with
this tomato plan and when you can
finally eat one of those Tomatoes the
ass all the time if you can pick me one
of those tomatoes and he finally gets to
pick that tomato and taste it and before
you know you can never get a tomato in
your salad because he's sneaking out
there and eating the tomatoes off the
vine what's that kid's consciousness and
relationship to that plant and that food
versus the adult who runs to the store
rushed between work and home pick up for
hydroponically grown to mezzo never
touch the earth you don't even have a
sense of concept of where that thing
comes from was probably from Chile or
Mexico or some far-flung space of the
universe you have no idea the work that
went into creating that vegetable Don in
rally most the work was probably not
done by a human or even the Sun it was
probably under fluorescent lighting is
probably in an artificial environment
start to finish
what's the consciousness of that tomato
in contrast what's the consciousness of
a piece of corn grown in the middle of a
1 million acre corn farm that is growing
row after row after row of a genetically
modified food that doesn't have the
nutrients or medicines that it was made
to be what is the purpose of that corn
it's gone the corn knows that I think
there is a decrease in energy field in
that corn
and it's weakened and we go and consume
that our beef consume it we consume the
beef the beef are nearly dead by the
time we eat that cow chickens even more
so a third of the flock of the chickens
by six weeks are already dead from
invasive infection and then we butcher
the surviving animals at six weekends
and call them boiler chickens and we put
them in a chick-fil-a sandwich or
whatever it is and and suddenly we've
got this maelstrom of stress in what we
think was just a bite of food the plants
that that animal ate was stressed the
animal itself was on the verge of death
woman when it was finally killed and
then we put that in our mouth and we
wonder why an hour later were having a
panic attack yeah I think I've tried to
remember who I was speaking to I believe
it was on the podcast somebody was
talking about how they've actually done
studies on the impact of the hormonal
stress that these animals are
experiencing when they're slaughtered
and what that does the human body this
is one of my main areas of interest
right now we've got large-scale cattle
trials going on up in in Canada right
now with a product that we've drill out
for cow intestines and we're super
excited about it's like restore for cows
like restore for cows and it's and Nexis
and poultry and then the pork or super
sorry about on so many levels number one
it reduces the amount of gut stress and
methane they produce methane from cows
is the number one greenhouse gas
produced in North America right now and
so we're gonna reduce greenhouse gases
by successfully implementing something
that reduces the stress of the gut of
the cows that's really cool but more
importantly it reduces the pain that the
cow is in and more importantly perhaps
it reestablishes the cell identity
self-identity of the cow and this is
what you see lacking when you walk
through a feedlot have I've been blessed
with the opportunity to to be on
feedlots in the last few years and it's
a fascinating to be a medical doctor and
in clinic that's full of a lot of
autistic kids and then go on a feed lawn
you see the exact same macro traits and
a cow on a feedlot as you do as a child
with autism they're skittish they can't
make eye contact the skitter away from
each other they startled at any sound
they they have lost their filter systems
just like the autistic child have and
they are prone to respiratory
actions they'll have acidic guts I mean
they just the biology is just like an
autistic kid and yet here I live in
Virginia where we have these bucolic
rolling hills with all these grass-fed
cows walking all over and then they're
sent just in the last few ly you know
days or weeks or months of their life to
a feedlot for fattening up and so I know
those cows that are around my fields my
daughter's favorite animals the cow a
lot of ways and so we'll stop on this
road side and these cows will look at
you for an hour staring into your face
blinking at you and then you see them a
couple months later on a feed line and
they are an autistic behavior and so
we're seeing this collapse of awareness
of the animals were consuming and I and
not only is it hormonal it's actually
again at the genetic level 99 percent of
the human genome and and some similar
percent and the other large mammals is
actually not making any proteins it
doesn't make a gene so 99 percent of our
genome makes what we call it junk DNA
literally scientists are calling this
junk 99% of the genome what's the chance
the Nature put 99% of the genome and
junk right well turns out it's not junk
at all it doesn't make a protein but it
makes something called micro RNA these
micro RNA turn on and change from second
to second until your genes exactly what
the environment is doing so if you
become stressed or you think your life
is threatened right now or you're lonely
or you're fearful you don't know where
truth is you start making a totally
different population of micro RNA that
goes into your bloodstream courses
through you and actually can excrete out
of you in your breath in your saliva and
all of your secretions are putting out
micro RNA to tell everything in your
environment that there is fight or
flight going on there is a war and
you're losing it that's what the cows
are right now putting into their
bloodstream into their meat right before
they die and so there's now butchered
and it goes into you and now you eat
that and we already know that five
percent of the micro RNA in your
bloodstream is from your last meal and
so your last meal is literally now going
into your genome and telling your genes
which genes to turn on and off and which
proteins to make from those genes and so
when you start to talk about a stressed
food chain you're literally talking
about a stressed consumer if all of this
is true then we should see a very close
correlation with antibiotic use and mu
disorder anxiety were paint attack major
depression and turns out those studies
have proven out very well one course of
antibiotics increases your rate of
depression by about 25 percent in the
following 12 months
well one course of antibiotics 25%
increase in your risk of major
depression one course of antibiotics
there's a 19% increase in the anxiety
attack and panic disorder if you have
two course of the disruption of the the
caliber and quality of the gut flora
exactly so you've now wiped out the gut
flora with the antibiotic which means
you've now lost the restore like
molecules that are doing that wireless
communication network which means you're
now leaking across the membrane which
means you're now over inflamed there and
the neurologic system is starting to get
hit as the blood-brain barrier fails and
so that's one course of a in a box if
you now take it up to two courses or
above we can get up to 60% increase
likelihood a major depression in a year
with multiple courses of antibiotics the
rate at which were prescribing
antibiotics as physicians hasn't changed
in the last 15 years which is
interesting statistic like the general
perception is we're using more
antibiotics all the time as doctors the
reason we haven't gone up in the number
of antibiotics prescribed per 1000
persons is because we literally can't
write more we hit 833 prescriptions per
1000 man why don't women and child back
in the mid-1990s 1-800 33 prescription
for every thousand people 83% of the
population being exposed in any given
year to an antibiotic by numbers of
course it's probably more like you know
some percentage of the population is
getting four or five courses of
antibiotics but nonetheless it's
literally be impossible for us to
prescribe more antibiotics so we
plateaued in our antibiotic prescription
thing but over the same course the
antibiotics used in our animals has gone
way out right and so we're using five
times more antibiotic today in our beef
pork and poultry industries than we are
in humans and then you'll add on top of
that so to give you numbers and pounds
we've got around seven seven point seven
million pounds of antibody used in
humans we have about 30 million pounds
of antibiotic used and in the animal
production in the North America in
contrast we have four and a half billion
pounds of glyphosate antibiotic in our
food chain and so again
you know we can show damage from
physician prescriptions we can show
damage from the antibiotics given
directly in animals but nothing touches
glyphosate in regard to is just sheer
capacity to kill the biome has Monsanto
responded I mean you're out like you're
giving talks like tort like twice a
month right you're on the road you're
getting up in front of doctors all
different kinds of audiences to speak
about these issues have they responded
to you at all like how is this being
received and and you know what's going
on on the regulatory level like can you
get this information in front of the EPA
like who's listening you know how do we
how do we promulgate this in a way that
we can actually provoke change yeah I
think you've on Santa has been paying
attention they put themselves up for
sale mm-hmm
Monsanto just sold themselves to bear
largest pharmaceutical company in the
world Bears got a little bit of a
riddled past Bayer actually came out
with the first patents for heroin in the
early nineteen hundred's right Bayer
created aspirin which was arguably the
most damaging there's been more deaths
from medical deaths from aspirin than
probably any other drug on the plan is
that true yeah and so we've got these
this checkered pass for a company that
now buys up Monsanto and so I think
Monsanto is paying attention not just to
me but to the American consumer that's
increasingly realizing we've got a
serious problem and the problem is is
interesting that it's really limited to
the US right now that we have so many
drug resistant weeds in our country now
that the glyphosate is failing as an
herbicide and so the number of pounds in
the US this and I was sold every year is
actually decreased for the first time in
the last couple years because we have to
spray more atrazine all these other more
noxious chemicals because all the weeds
have become resistant to Roundup it's
this accelerating insane cycle right we
have to hybridize even further create
additional GMO and then increase the
potency of the glyphosate or whatever
you know fertilizers are being used
it's exactly like warfare you know my
brother was overnight Iraq for a number
of years and Afghanistan other places
and and I watched the same thing he's a
next
and ie D analysis and he gets to watch
you know an insurgent group create a new
technology of IEDs so then the u.s.
comes and says oh here's a new
technology so they create a new
technology around that they give it to
the US government and then the
insurgents see that and they just
engineer around that so there's this
constant evolving thing and my brother's
just always like this is the most
worthless journey ever but the pretty
how the perspective is flawed from the
inception of it because we shouldn't be
at war with our environment we should be
looking to work in conjunction with it
exactly which is the same with the
humans right we shouldn't be killing the
insurgent we just go sit down and talk
to the insurgents we have to feed the
planet you know this is GMO is the
future there's a lot of smart people
very smart people who are telling me
people like Bill Gates look you want to
feed the planet you want to feed
everybody we're gonna have 10 billion
people soon how you gonna do it GMO is
how we're gonna do it so get out of the
way be part of the solution or you know
let us do our job
that's right we're starved to death if
we don't have GMO 1996 was the rate of
starvation on the planet any higher than
it is now
no we have exactly the same distribution
of starvation and famine going on in the
world as we did in 1996 many would argue
it's actually worse now than it was in
1996 before we had GMO crops they talked
as if at some distant past that we were
relying on normal crops in 1996 we were
just fine we can scale farming in this
country log rhythmically by just
stopping the subsidies to pay farmers
not to grow anything all right we have
so much farmland that can feed the world
and the the biggest misperception with
GMO is that it increases crop yield you
can have to be extremely myopic or
short-sighted to believe that it
increases crop yield because if you are
killing the bacteria and fungi in the
soil what's the chance that soil is
going to keep growing lots of crop in
ten years the answer is zero and so they
address that in the short run by more
NPK fertilizer more chemicals to get in
there more chemicals herbicides
pesticides to deal with the sick crop
but by seven years in farmers are
recognizing drops in in their yield and
the fact is GMOs not gonna feed the
world because you are killing the soil
in which the plants grow and so you're
not gonna survive much beyond
five or seven years with your with your
soil if you're constantly spraying the
roundup in there and you can palliate
that for a long time you now have dead
soil that you keep palliating with
chemicals but the reality is you're
never going to feed the world on sick
and dead soil so how are we gonna feed
the world we're gonna do it by the
farmers all we really have to do is get
back the part farmers are the most
resilient most brilliant problem solvers
I've ever worked around they are so damn
smart because they're paying attention
to mother nature
the scary thing though is that our
farmers are at like average age 67 in
this country we don't have a younger
generation learning the wisdom of our
experienced farmers but I think there is
a there is a generation of Millennials
who are interested in permaculture and
are studying sustainable ecological
systems and farming like when I was in
college nobody was going to you know go
work on farms and you know Costa Rica
and Hawaii and now that's a thing so I'm
actually encouraged by it I'm absolutely
encouraged by that generation my kids
are 20 and 18 and I'm watching their
generation and something like organic
food is so cotton-picking obvious to
their generation it's just not even a
question in their minds and like that
you should be eating organic you know
and in the same way you know both my
kids are highly plant-based you know
more strict than I am in many ways not
because I taught them to be because they
are looking at the world just being like
this is completely the only way we can
pull this thing off and so to these
younger generations I agree with you
they are far more conscious of the
problem and they're far more interested
in some real meaningful solutions so my
greatest joy is to see exactly what's
afoot
we're shooting a documentary film next
week on the Mississippi River going
recording the rely force a roundup
levels from from Minnesota all the way
down to Louisiana Baton Rouge by the way
at the end of that Mississippi River the
last 90 miles of the Mississippi River
that's collected all of the roundup out
of our whole bread belt of our country
is the highest rates of cancer in the
entire developed world it's called in
the cancer alley and we have a lot of
people that are self in their fourth and
fifth cancers that live in that
territory and so we're documenting all
this but one of the coolest teams that
were partnering up with is this group of
four very experienced older farmers who
are now traveling
the country teaching people how to
convert thirty thousand hundred thousand
acre farms back to an organic and
permaculture type thing this is the
revolution I think because it's one
thing for us to send out some
Millennials and grow you know a ten acre
or twenty acre permaculture garden and
and fuel another thing to teach
large-scale farmers to convert back to
thousands of years of food tradition to
grow on the grand scale enough healthy
food that's happening right now this is
not fiction and so you know we hope to
be at least some of the documentaries
coming out to document that this is
stupid easy we've been doing it for ten
thousand years we just need to keep
doing it which is growing healthy food
respecting the soil growing healthy soil
and seeing human health come right out
of spring right out of that soil that we
were born into right so if you if you
rotate it properly or you tend to the
soil you know in a kind of more holistic
fashion you don't run into this these
problems that monoculture was producing
and it's very exciting how fast you can
return to that you can still get the
yields and higher yields you can get
three or four years in there starting to
recover the yields that they expected
from chemical farming you know so you
can get higher yields from from cover
cropping then after three or four years
of cover crop you'll get better yields
than continuous chemical farming well my
hope is that as as the kind of
plant-based movement continues to to
grow that it will you know and meet meat
consumption continues to reduce that
that frees up some of the the the land
that we're using to grow feed for these
animals is a huge issue and a problem
right so to the extent that that can be
shifted for human consumption and
diversified I think we're on the path to
a better way forward you're part of it I
mean this podcast is a critical piece of
this every every the podcast industry is
so exciting to me I've been on thousands
of these shows and without them this
information would have gotten out this
information has been known for a long
time but it happened now because of this
kind of form of media and communication
so we've been talking about cell so
communication but ultimately we're in
relationship with every one of your
listeners right now and I know by what
I've seen over the last five years is
you can't put this truth in some of
these hands and they can they can't keep
it silent now
they have to know intermediary I mean I
don't know what your relationship has
been with mainstream media but I would
imagine it's pretty difficult for a guy
like you to end up on Good Morning
America or the Today Show when their
advertiser base is the pharmaceutical
industry and these big food companies
that rely on glyphosate that and you
know basically these are mmm these are
adjuncts of the Monsanto complex right
and and they've created a situation
through their own social media efforts
of trying to convince people that
anybody that that speaks askance of
their party line is some kind of crazy
conspiracy theorist so you have that
what's the who's the guy Ken falta is
that he was like their mouthpiece for a
while before he kind of sort of got
exposed right and we're starting to be
able to see through these people but I
think it's important for everybody to
understand that you have to kind of
approach this war for the hearts and
minds of the populace with with some
awareness and some consciousness to try
to see through the arguments that are
being presented to you and really you
know take it upon yourself to do the
research to mine to mine the truth one
of the reasons I think the truth is
bulletproof here is that you would have
to come up with a better story than I've
told you as to why we have an epidemic
of every chronic disease known on the
planet simultaneously starting the late
late 80s early 90s
they're gonna have to come up with a
better story than mine I mean I have
proved out all the science and all the
details yet and everything else but
they're gonna have to and so that's why
they're staying silent with this is they
know they don't have a better story the
science has proved it out to the level
that we know and the this the history is
ironclad the the public health data is
ironclad and so they would have been
it's stacked against them and so we see
the largest food owner in the world
selling themselves for 66 million
dollars to bear 66 million dollars is
nothing in this world or I'm sorry 66
billion 66 billion dollars is nothing
when you're talking about the world food
chain that they own 80% of this sort of
Union pharma and come
all right exactly so who would want to
own a company that this main product
takes the medicinals out of food a
company that makes medicine and so
that's literally what we do let me give
you a little bit of an expose if you
don't mind this dragging a little bit
longer we can go as long as you want
gotcha Senor time but I could talk to
you all day we have to cut it short like
that you have to please come back is
like there's play work this is a service
of all this kind of stuff but go ahead
so my background with with chemotherapy
there's one of the most widely used
chemo therapies on the planets called
vincristine this man christine it turns
out is a normally occurring naturally
occurring alkaloid one of these
medicines and food that occurs in a lot
of the superfoods that you would think
to eat these alkaloids are made through
the Shikha main pathway that glyphosate
blocks we've literally subtracted out of
our food chain this form of chemotherapy
if you will we now grow the way in which
we produce being Christine you can't do
that in a test tube you have to get it
from plants and so the way they do this
is they grate hugebass of algae that
create vincristine and we we extract it
from the plant source and then we purify
it down to the single chemical and we
sell it for twenty eight thousand
dollars a gram it's some you know
tenfold more expensive than gold as like
an anti-cancer as a chemo therapeutic
there as well but this is available if
you were just eating foods the way that
they were naturally designed you would
you would have a constant low-grade
non-toxic available vincristine that
would be bathing the cells to make sure
that if there was cancer there it would
be informed and I often Wow that's crazy
all right so you've painted this sort of
dystopian you know fixture of of food in
America
glyphosate sand everything it's in the
rainwater even if you're growing an
organic garden in your backyard the
chances are the soil is compromised
what is how can we move forward like
what are some of the things that we can
that we can do to rectify this and to
eat as healthy and take care of
ourselves as best as we can
perfect concrete next
steps for you if you're listening to
this you're you're trying to put heads
or tails together let's keep it simple
and before you even worry about what
you're inputting your mouth let's start
thinking about mechanisms for you
reintroduce the microbiome to your body
number one in my very favorite one is to
breathe as many environments as you can
turns out we can repopulate our
microbiome not just by eating it through
more fermented foods which I love but by
breathing the bacteria and fungi in our
environment how do you do that you
simply get out of your house get out on
a hike get near a waterfall get to a
swamp get up into the mountains get into
many macro ecosystems as you can and
breathe air for a few hours
ferns are a really good sign if you're
out in the woods and you see ferns
growing they're nutrient base is the
oldest ecosystem on the plate planet a
ferns not going to grow unless it has
access to the oldest ecosystem on the
planet and so go next to a fern and sit
there and read a book for half an hour
in the sunshine or in the dappled shade
where those ferns are growing sit and
read and breathe for a bit you're going
to repopulate your micro biome and
you're gonna have a spiritual experience
of sitting under a tree when was the
last time you felt grass between your
toes or ran down a field of flat
wildflowers we don't do these basic
things and so we even created in these
micro eco systems in our drywall homes
and everything else and the reality is
it's so easy as an American to change
that environment if you're not happy
with the body you have then go pick one
of the other 399 million that you can
build tomorrow by breathing something
different so get out into many
ecosystems you can make sure that your
weekends involve diversity yeah if
you're stuck in an office most of the
week make sure you're getting out not
just to spray down roundup no weeds but
you're getting out actually that's it
beneath a tree and stare up in the sky
and stare at a cloud floating over and
realize you are a speck on a speck in
the universe that it has to describe
some greater purpose to you than
cranking away on a computer and a
cubicle somewhere you are greater than
your mission is much bigger than that
and it has to do with communication with
your fellow people and so get into
community with your co-workers get into
community with your your neighborhood
get it in the community and we see again
and again all the solutions come right
out of that
you know these little farms that are
popping up CSAs we got neighborhoods
that are banding together to create
neighborhood gardens again the solutions
are at hand and they are happening and
all you need to do is participate in
them by getting out of your drywall box
and the plastic infused car that you sit
in all day get out of those spaces and
re-engage the number one macro ecosystem
shift number two start about getting
fermented foods back in your diet we ate
these through all human history every
people group on the planet until
refrigeration hit in the 1950s and we
stopped from any our foods we just
started sticking in the fridge instead
so get back to fermenting your own food
if you can if not then spend the expense
of money on getting a wild fermented
sauerkraut sour Reuben kvass any of
these fermented vegetables back in your
diet it only takes about a tablespoon or
two to eat it you don't want a typical
sauerkraut that's just made with a
probiotic probiotics are chasing after
the wind three species or one species of
bacteria you need in like the VSL threes
and the fancy ones and all of them yeah
so VSL number three is three species of
probiotic that we prove down in one tiny
clinical trial to help impact
inflammatory bowel disease as the only
real studies that ever been done on VSL
number three it's three bacteria that
don't actually colonize a normal human
gut they are actually colonized from or
bovine guts and so 99% of the well more
than that 99.9% of the products on the
market and probiotic industry are
bacteria that grow in the bovine
intestine bovines have room and guts not
the acidic stomachs that the human has
and so we have a much different
microbiome and so the cows bacteria that
we're now taking the form of we're
selling three and a half billion dollars
of probiotics a year in this country
that's that's because we're all sick and
that's the only tool we've been handed
and I also think it's a it's a canoe
it's it's something that works with the
human mind because you can it's sort of
like taking a pills like oh I don't have
to worry about my gut flora because I
take a probiotic I'm good yeah exactly I
have to think about it anymore
it's supposed to the real solution which
is diversifying your life experience you
know get back out that's hard that takes
effort that takes intention and
consciousness and awareness it takes a
shift in lifestyle which is challenging
it's difficult to change the way we
spend the minutes in a day right and so
all right
so and I would I would presume I'd be
shocked if you said differently but like
if somebody says well should I buy
organic food you should you should have
coral reefs ins number one you change
the industry if we enrage sixteen
percent will collapse Bayer in
Monsanto's and anything else by taking
away their financial capacities it to
keep all that expensive chemicals say
they look it is it is more expensive
there are some organic foods that are
better than others but I would imagine
you're you're an absolutist right I was
I would say not necessarily ewg is great
website so easy WG it has the clean
fifteen and the Dirty Dozen if you just
Google is already does in clean fifteen
you'll come up with the e DWG website
and what it shows you is the twelve
crops that in the conventional form are
the highest and roundup and other
pesticides herbicides and the fifteen
cleanest ones that even grown
conventionally have almost no trace
chemical on them and so in this way you
can if you're really strapped for money
you can go to the grocery store okay an
avocado doesn't need to be organic
there's hardly any pesticide herbicides
its technical Nava cada even if it's
conventionally grown however it's a
strawberry be absolutist never put a
non-organic strawberry in front of your
children that is a chemical bomb right
there and so those are the ways you can
kind of start to tease out where do we
have to be absolutist and strict and
where can we kind of feeling a little
more lenient ultimately it's really
exciting because the demand of organic
crops is dropping the price and that's
natural right we're going to get cheaper
crops in the long run the cost goes in
the wall in the Walmarts and all of that
becoming the biggest retailers of
organic food yeah you know it's it's
crazy so that is a huge paradigm shift
yes well to if you don't know about
thrive market do that thrive market
online such a brilliant brilliant
concept and they're literally passing on
wholesale prices of organic food to the
consumer and you can order your
groceries online they come the next day
as an amazing beautiful model they have
they're a sponsor of this show Oh
Kenard is a friend I was a ganar lawyer
in a venture that like back when we were
both living different oh my god he's one
guy said he's got a great vision and
it's pulled together something beautiful
there well there's there's an
unintentional plug for your for your
supporters there
but yeah I mean so I think the argument
that it's more expensive is is quickly
being proven wrong it's not more
expensive to grow healthy food is
cheaper because you're not spending all
that money on the chemical fertilizers
or pesticides and everything else it may
take a few years for the farmer to
realize those profit margins but that's
better than being stuck in and
completely you know feudal state of Co
dependence on a chemical farming
industry where you're never going to get
out of debt if you're a chemical farmer
what is your opinion on all of these new
microbiome tech startups where you can
have your gut flora tested and evaluated
and then you get this litany of sort of
advice about how to proceed it cracks me
up
and largely it's like yeah because what
are we really going to learn we're gonna
find out that we have leaky gut which
which it always shows and we're gonna
find out that we're sensitive most of
foods we eat because we have leaky gut
not because the foods are bad and then
we're gonna find out that we should eat
more fruits and vegetables and so in the
end the genomics are never really to
prove out anything other than the
obvious because the obvious has has
taken us such a few decades to destroy
and so the obvious thing is stop
spraying chemical fertilizers stop
sprayed chemical treatments on top of
our crops start eating real food and
suddenly the microbiome is gonna respond
our microbiome is only challenge because
we're drenching it in in antibiotics but
in the meantime like should I get a
fecal transplant I would say no and the
reason is is because again it's a
transient fix right so you know it can
be a great tool for somebody who's dying
from C difficile colitis really acute
like problem right yeah intractable
autoimmune disease or you know your
insurance company will only pay for seed
if colitis that's the only indication
they'll pay for but out of pocket
there's a lot of places around the
country where you can start to pay for
fecal transplants but in reality that's
just a patch job at the end because the
microbiome turns over every three days
so if you're not supporting that
microbiome that you just translated into
the that recipient with a new diet with
a new environment with something that
would sustain that microbiome was gonna
be gone in three days and so that's
where the the misperception of the of
the utility of fecal transplant kind of
comes in right and I would imagine that
kind of hand in hand with that is some
awareness of how we navigate the world
in terms of like how we over sanitized
with the Purell everywhere and all you
know the way that we wash everything and
you know what's your position on like
just basically the antiperspirant and
soap and showering a lot and like all of
the kind of you know human behaviors
that we've all agreed on are sort of
what we do and the impact that that has
on health and gut health yeah it's all
I'm gonna let you go in front we're all
at every one of those levels were
separating ourselves from nature right
and so something like an aluminum based
deodorant one of the most tragic things
for a neuron you can't do more brain
damage I think with a topical therapy
than aluminum based deodorant and so we
need to phase those out they need to be
illegal and we've proven that that
aluminum gets into the body we've proven
that aluminum is the most toxic thing
neurons we've got to stop the use of
aluminum based cosmetics and then you
mentioned soap and showering you know
obviously the place in which we used to
get most of our magnesium was from
bathing you know in live streams in
ocean water well we don't do that
anymore and so we're all magnet
deficient it's very hard to actually
replete the human body for magnesium
through the gut and through to your diet
or through taking supplements it does
great coming through the skin and so we
we aren't bathing in natural waters
anymore I have the advantage of living
in Virginia where I'm on a 450 foot deep
well into these deep aquifers where I'm
getting a ton of mineral content in
there and so I think I'm a little better
off in a deep well then I would be from
a municipal water system in regard to
getting some of those nutrients on my
skin but on their hand there's gonna be
glyphosate in there as well it's gonna
be unclean so the realities we need to
change the macro system of farming
before we really get back to a natural
water system that we would bay then we
weigh over soap alcohol the sanitizers
are really ironic isn't it I mean every
flu season they start popping up in
every grocery store and everything else
this is washing hands wash your hands
wash your hands well the reality is the
vast majority of the viruses that are
gonna cause flu or any other upper
respiratory infection are airborne not
translated by a hand you don't get flu
by shaking somebody's hand you get flu
from from breathing the air that they've
just exhaled and so washing your hands
into Oblivion's never gonna change that
flu flu vulnerability and so I think
there's some irony in in the
sterilization belief because you're not
really sterilizing anything
by washing your hands you simply change
the microbiome on your hands you're
gonna be more prone to cracking skin and
you know issues of eczema on your hands
and everything else rather than anything
like a public health event awesome man
all right well I'm gonna let you go but
I'm gonna leave you with one last
question and I always I asked this to
every doctor that I have on the show if
you if you woke up and found yourself in
a parallel universe and you were Surgeon
General what's the first order of
business first order of business is
absolutely to create a ten year plan to
eliminate all chemical spraying on our
crops and that's not just glyphosate
we're now springing all kinds of insane
cousins to the the Agent Orange compound
that we sprayed on the jungles of
Vietnam on our crops because they're so
diseased we have to stop spray and let
the ecosystem return there would be no
bigger public health event than stopping
the spring we will see human health
rebound so quickly if we will stop
spraying and so number one do that
number two I would demand that the
government created a new sector which
would be the equivalent of the Peace
Corps and make it the green corps and
every kid by the age of 18 has to sign
up for work on a farm somewhere in our
country that's a great idea spend one
year on a farm and you will have a
different perspective on what you want
to do with your life and your connection
to mother nature and if we Israel's done
a great job building the best military
in the world lets us build the greatest
farming in nation in the world
let's retrain our children to train us
how to gray and grow and grow their
greatest food on earth I feel like you
could do that like create sort of like a
Peace Corps version of that if something
like that doesn't already exist it needs
to happen yeah yeah and there's small
versions of it and that's encouraging
there's a nice element our high school
in our community in Charlottesville
Virginia that now has a specialty track
for advanced kids who are kind of gifted
and talented program where they can
actually opt into this high school from
any school district in the area and they
run a green house themselves and so
those been three years with the green
house and during high school and they
come out with directions in the botany
biology in all kinds of different
science fields so it's already starting
to happen on micro levels but it would
be beautiful to see a Surgeon General
step up and say we have a new
we have a core this is our new belief
system we are going to train the best of
the best and this is a calling that you
have the opportunity to be and I think
our children would jump right in with
enthusiasm all I don't think it's going
to happen with this administration maybe
it's just crazy enough to do something
like that all bets are off
yeah all bets are off I just you know
I'm ready for crazy because the old
status quo is not working and so you
know well there's a few decisions that
are being made at the government level
that I can tolerate in any shape or form
I do have hope of chaos because out of
chaos will come new new opportunities
perhaps all right man well thanks for uh
thanks for taking the time today Zach
thanks for your time virtually she ativ
loved it beautiful super inspiring I
please come back because there's a
million other things I could talk oh
yeah yeah I'm sure I'll be back in the
area in the next few months and we'll
just line it up again right cool and if
you're digging on Zach the best way to
connect with him is Busch MD com correct
and the EM clinic comm which is your
clinic in Virginia and you're seeing
patients I presume yep yeah we've got
there my nurse practitioners Jude
Christian is amazing kitchen if you
needed some help there but the EM clinic
has rolled out an eight-week intensive
program where we pair you with a life
coach that's going to help you through
this journey of applying a completely
new life style that goes way beyond
nutrition it gets into exercise
physiology breathing meditation all
kinds of different levels of human
consciousness and so that's an
eight-week program is available online
wherever you live and it's cheaper than
traveling to Virginia so we've really
rolled this out with the intention of
making it cheaper for you and consume a
lot of the important data we have for
you and along the way you have an
incredible health coach that's really
training you know to find the truth
that's inside of yourself because
healing doesn't come from me it's going
to help it happen from you and it's it's
the accountability and having a you know
a sustainable program with whom you're
you're actively engaged with another
human being
absolutely for more details on the soil
science and all that the restore for
life website can get you that story and
I restore the number four life.com it'll
take you into kind of the details of
this
wireless communication network we've
discovered it and take you through a lot
of that story so if you're curious
there's a lot more digesting to do yeah
cool and I'll have I'll have links up to
all that stuff in the show notes for
people that want to go down the Zach
rabbit hole yeah that'll keep you busy
the GMO revealed is a great product that
Patrick and tempo and the revealed films
team has created it's it's a ton of
information if you're really interested
in this it's over 22 hours of content
from 16 of the greatest minds and in
science out there and so really
brilliant people speaking to this issue
of soil science and genetically modified
foods and the herbicides pesticides and
their impact on human health and
ultimately I think you're gonna walk
away encouraged not discouraged that
there's an opportunity for us to now
identifying the problem move forward
quickly to the summations well I watched
episode one so I think there's eight or
nine more of them yeah yeah nine to go
but he mows reveal it's on YouTube or at
least some of them are on YouTube but
I'll put the links up to all that kind
of stuff in the show notes and that's it
man thanks Austin
so good thanks